نقل صحيفه عن مسؤولينا امريكيين ان غاره
بطائره مسيره استهدفت مظلوم عبدي قائد ما
يسمى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في مطار
السليمانيه بشمال العراق امس الجمعه
واضافت الصحيفه ان ثلاثه عسكريين امريكيين
كانوا برفقه مظلوم عبد مشيره الى عدم
تسجيل اصابات ونسبت الصحيفه الى مسؤولين
غرديين ترجيحهم ان الضربه ربما نفذتها
تركيا
وفي ردود الفعل دانت الرئاسه العراقيه
اليوم وصفته بالاعتداءات السافره من جانب
تركيا على سياده العراقيه مشيره الى
الهجوم الاخير الذي استهدف مطار سليمانيه
وطلبت في بيان الحكومه التركيه بتحمل
المسؤوليه وتقديم اعتذار رسمي عن هذه
التصرفات ووقفي هذه الاعتداءات وقالت
الرئاسه العراقيه انه في حال تكرار هذه
الاعتداءات فسيكون هناك موقف حازم لمنع
تكرارها مستقبلا بدورها نددت رئاسه اقليم
كردستان العراق باستهداف مطار السليمانيه
وطالبت في بيان طرفي حكومه الاقليم باداء
واجبهم للتحقيق في مصادر واسباب الحادث
معنا من اربيل مراسله الجزيره امير سندي
اذا امير اجواء متوتره في ضوء هذه الاحداث
يعيشها اقليم كردستان العراق كيف تتم
معالجه هذه الاوضاع وماذا في اخر مواقف
المسؤولين في الاقليم
نعم بالفعل حسن الاجواء تبدو في الغالب هي
متوتره سياسيا هنا في اقليم كردستان
العراق بعد تعمق الخلاف بين طرفي حكومه
اقليم كردستان العراق الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الذي يقود الحكومه والاتحاد
الوطني لكردستاني الذي يشارك كشريك وبقوه
في هذه الحكومه وكان قد اعلن فريق الاتحاد
انسحابه من كافه الاجتماعات التي يعقدها
مجلس وزراء اقليم كردستان العراق وجاء هذا
القصف الاخير
ليعمق من هذه الخلافات حيث اتهمت حكومه
اربيل السلطات في السليمانيه وتحديدا
الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
باستغلال مطار السليمانيه الدولي لاغراض
غير قانونيه هكذا وصفها البيان الحكومي من
جهتها ايضا في السليمانيه الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني
ادانا هذا القصف وقال
ما تدعيه حكومه اربيل من سيطرتها على
المطار والقيام باعمال غير قانونيه هو امر
عار على الصحه في هذه الاثناء وقبل ذلك
بايام قليله كانت انقره قد اعلنت اغلاق
الاجواء امام مطار السليمانيه الدولي بسبب
ما وصفته باعمال مناوئه تهدد امنها القومي
رئاسه اقليم كردستان العراق دعت طرفي
الحكومه الى التوقف عن تبادل الاتهامات
والتحقيق في ملابسات هذا القصف الاخير
الذي قالت عنه اداره مطار السليمانيه انه
طال جزءا كبيرا من سورها الخارجيه والحق
اضرار جسيمه فيه دون وقوع اي اضرار او
ضحايا بشريه ولكن هذا الجو المتوتر بين
طرفي حكومه اقليم كردستان ياتي في خضم
وقوع هذا القصف
وتوقف الاجواء مع مطار السليمانيه من قبل
تركيا ليتعمق هذا الخلاف في حين الجميع
هنا ينتظر ان تنتهي هذه الخلافات
للاستعداد للانتخابات التشريعيه القادمه
التي من المقرر ان تجرى في الربع الاخير
من هذا العام شكرا جزيلا لك امير فندي
مراسل الجزيره احدثتنا من اربيل